[Aplausos]
[Música]
bueno buenas noches
hace más de 20 años cuando estaba
finalizando mi carrera de médica
tuve una rotación por gineco-obstetricia
sigue cargada de expectativas y ansiedad
ya que era una de las especialidades que
pensaba como posibles para mi futuro
esto probablemente estuvo influenciado
por mi amor por la embriología en mi
carrera de médica
yo fui ayudante de la cátedra de
biología durante cinco años y adoraba el
módulo de embriología me fascinaba
contarle a los alumnos como un puñado de
células sufría transformaciones día a
día hasta convertirse en un feto maduro
con cuatro miembros un corazón latente y
un cerebro listo para registrar las
impresiones y en un futuro elaborar los
pensamientos más sofisticados demás está
decir que en mi cabeza de aquellos años
no había mucho espacio para pensar en el
aborto como algo posible
y mucho menos como un derecho
mire se embarcó en aquella rotación fue
perturbador e inquietante
lo primero que me impactó fue ver como
las mujeres eran escindidas por completo
del proceso de toma de decisiones acerca
de cómo llevar adelante sus embarazos y
cómo parir como si los deseos y
expectativas de las mujeres a la hora de
reproducirse gestar y finalmente traer
un hijo al mundo no tuviesen ningún
valor
desde un lugar paternalista o
autoritario el sistema se volvía
violento contra la mujer
pero mucho mayor fue mi perplejidad al
ver el maltrato al que eran sometidas
las mujeres que llegaban a la guardia
con un aborto incompleto
el sistema de salud que recibía estas
mujeres es decir médicos obstétricas
enfermeros e incluso personal
administrativo no sólo no exhibía ni una
mínima cuota de empatía con estas pobres
mujeres sino que además se arrogaba el
derecho a juzgar las y al asumir las
como delincuentes eran supuestas
merecedoras de todo tipo del estrato
incluso a ser atendidas con displicencia
muchas de estas mujeres motivadas por la
vergüenza por el miedo al maltrato por
el miedo a la denuncia policial recién
acudían al hospital cuando ya no había
mucho para hacer y muchas de ellas
morían desangradas o infectadas no sin
antes haber sido debidamente
interrogadas por autoridades policiales
es decir mujeres policías que les pedían
que revelaran quien les había practicado
el aborto
no solo decidí que gineco-obstetricia no
era la especialidad para mí sino que
además experimenté una crisis vocacional
al reconocer que no me sentía
identificada ni mucho menos cómoda con
cierto paradigma de médico tan popular
por aquellos años
yo vivía lejos de la facultad y entonces
me reunía con una compañera que vivía
más cerca a estudiar y a veces pasaba
largas temporadas en su casa
todas las tardes maría su empleada
doméstica nos traía amorosamente la
merienda y siempre nos compartía cosas
de su vida maría tenía 24 años y tres
hijos de cinco cuatro y dos años
un día la vimos muy perturbada y al
preguntarle qué le pasaba maría nos dijo
con lágrimas en los ojos que estaba
embarazada y que no podía tener un hijo
más nos pidió ayuda nos pidió ayuda para
interrumpir la gestación
nosotras la escuchamos la abrazamos
intentamos contenerla y a continuación
escribimos los mil y un argumentos para
hacerla desistir de su decisión
maría con la mirada perdida en el suelo
sentía en silencio
por esos caprichos de la vida al día
siguiente me encontré con una amiga muy
cercana lucía que me contó muy
angustiada que estaba embarazada
lucia tenía 25 años este año se había
recibido de ingeniera
y recientemente se había ganado una beca
para hacer un posgrado en francia'
este embarazo totalmente imprevisto la
conmocionó profundamente porque si bien
ella deseaba ser madre en un futuro de
ninguna manera esperaba que esto
sucediera en este momento tampoco
lisandro su novio y me contó que ambos
estaban pensando en interrumpir la
gestación
como con mariah fue incapaz de ponerme
en su lugar fue incapaz de ponerme en
sus zapatos
intenté contenerla como pude y luego
detalle las mil razones para intentar
convencerla de seguir adelante con las
fiestas
durante una semana pensé recurrentemente
en maría y en lucía
experimente los sentimientos más
ambivalentes comprendía las razones de
maría y de lucia pero continuaba
cuestionando las
tenía un examen final muy próximo y la
verdad es que no podía concentrarme en
el estudio por lo que decidí igualmente
ir a estudiar a la casa de mi compañera
a ver si en su compañía podíamos avanzar
un poco en el estudio al llegar mi
compañera me contó que estaba muy
preocupada porque maría esa semana no
había ido a trabajar y tampoco había
llamado para decir por qué
a partir de ese momento lo único que me
interesaba saber lo único que me
obsesionaba a saber no eran los
contenidos del examen sino que había
pasado con mariah intentamos localizar
la infructuosa mente imagínense hace 20
años prácticamente no existían los
teléfonos celulares hasta que finalmente
recordamos que una prima de maría
trabajaba en la casa de otra compañera
de la facultad así que llamamos y ella
nos dijo entristecida que hacía un par
de días que maría estaba internada
estaba internada en el hospital en el
que nosotras estábamos rotando
nos pusimos el unb o el guardapolvo y
corrimos al hospital al llegar
nos enteramos que maría estaba muy grave
que ese día había subido a terapia
intensiva el diagnóstico era shock
séptico a foco ginecológico
y abajo se veía aborto provocado
perforación uterina pronóstico reservado
es decir maría padecía una grave
infección provocada por una perforación
del útero por un cuerpo extraño lo que
había ocasionado una peritonitis tan
virulenta que al generalizarse había
causado daño de órganos vitales en
definitiva la situación de maría era
crítica
recuerdo aún las emociones de ese
momento salir del hospital desolada
desarmada confundida contrariada enojada
profundamente enojada enojada con mariah
enojada conmigo misma enojada con el
sistema de salud llame a lucía
desesperada temía que corriera la misma
suerte
quería advertirle que podía ser
peligroso hacerse un aborto pero lucía
me contó que había podido hablar de esto
con sus padres y que ellos finalmente le
habían acompañado una clínica en donde
se había realizado un aborto seguro
a los dos días volvía al hospital para
mi cursada regular y me enteré que maría
había fallecido
esto fue una bisagra en mi vida hubo un
antes y un después este desgraciado
hecho completamente evitable me
interpeló me llevó a cuestionarme
profundos dogmas éticos religiosos
morales y sembró en mí la semilla de la
duda
en los años posteriores de ejercicio
profesional
fui de apoco deshilvanando mis axiomas y
celebré el riquísimo debate que se dio
en el congreso y también en la sociedad
en los últimos dos años
lo primero que me cuestioné fue el tema
del inicio de la vida que si la vida
comienza en la concepción o cuando ya
está conformado el embrión o cuando éste
se transforma en feto o si finalmente
sucede después del nacimiento
busque argumentos argumentos científicos
y de los otros y les digo la verdad nada
me satisfizo porque aunque nos cueste
aceptarlo hay cosas que no tienen una
única respuesta
pero sobre todo porque mientras yo y
seguramente muchas otras personas nos
quedábamos detenidas en este punto
literalmente atascadas atrapadas en este
punto
muchas mujeres mueren en argentina a
causa de abortos inseguros muchas
jóvenes mujeres mueren por esta causa y
otras tantas quedan secuelas de por vida
pretender imponer en nombre de la verdad
posiciones metas físicas diferentes
respecto al origen de la vida no sólo es
imposible sino que también es inútil
indagué en el mundo de la filosofía y me
clarificaron mucho las reflexiones de un
conocido filósofo argentino aprendí que
lo metafísico es decir lo que va más
allá de la física de la naturaleza hace
referencia a todas aquellas cuestiones
que por su condición su carácter exceden
cualquier forma de comprobación última y
por lo tanto siempre terminan auto
justificándose a sí mismas
es por esto que jamás va a existir
acuerdo entre posiciones metafísicas
opuestas respecto al origen de la vida
sin embargo el debate acerca de este
tema que es sanitario que es un grave
problema de salud pública no puede ni
debe quedar centrado en este punto
porque no es importante lo que yo piense
en mi fuero íntimo acerca de si me haría
o no un aborto
porque además de sancionarse esta ley va
a regir el principio de autonomía y por
lo tanto nadie va a poder obligar a una
mujer a practicarse un aborto
debemos poder superar sin pretender
ponernos de acuerdo en estas diferentes
posiciones metas físicas que son todas
respetables para poder establecer
políticas sanitarias que son urgentes
porque nos guste o no el aborto es una
realidad inobjetable
porque en argentina suceden alrededor de
500.000 abortos por año porque desde
1983 a esta parte murieron tres mil
treinta mujeres a causa de abortos
clandestinos y estas cifras son
estimativas porque al tratarse de una
práctica clandestina existe un marcado
subregistro así que es posible que el
número sea aún mayor
pero además tengamos en cuenta que 5 de
cada 10 mujeres que mueren acars a causa
de abortos inseguros son menores de 25
años
diversas experiencias demuestran que una
mujer que está decidida a abortar lo va
a hacer el punto es sí lo va a ser en
condiciones de seguridad o inseguridad a
veces incluso en condiciones
infrahumanas como el caso de lucia
perdón de maría
no podemos seguir empujando a las
mujeres a la clandestinidad porque esto
se convierte en un nuevo reflejo de las
profundas desigualdades sociales de
nuestro país
cada mujer que se desangra a causa de un
aborto inseguro merece una respuesta del
estado
y está bien estudiado que cuando los
marcos normativos son restrictivos las
tasas de mortalidad materna aumentan
la penalización del aborto lejos de
disminuir el número de abortos impide el
acceso a procedimientos seguros y esto
pone en grave riesgo a la salud de la
mujer y a la vida de la mujer
este es el mapa mundial
que muestra la distribución de los
países de acuerdo a su estatus legal
respecto a la ley de despenalización del
aborto en verde están todos los países
que tienen una ley que despenaliza el
aborto en diciembre de 2018 se sumó
irlanda
en américa del sur como verán son muy
pocos los países que tienen una ley que
despenaliza el aborto en este sentido
nuestro vecino país
uruguay fue pionero en este tema y
después de haber sufrido la muerte de
muchas mujeres jóvenes a causa de
abortos inseguros tomó el tema y en el
año 2012
legalizó el aborto y a partir de esa
fecha las tasas de mortalidad materna
cayeron significativamente incluso son
cercanas a cero
de hecho uruguay es uno de los países
con menor tasa de mortalidad materna de
américa y según los índices de la
organización mundial de la salud tengan
presente que una vez que se legaliza el
aborto la tasa de abortos también
disminuye porque estos protocolos
siempre van acompañados de programas de
educación sexual que además facilitan el
acceso oportuno a métodos
anticonceptivos
los años pasaron ya quedó atrás aquella
rotación por gineco-obstetricia
finalmente mi especialidad profesional
es la infectología que me encanta
tengo una familia dos hijos hermosos a
los que me gustaría llegarles un mundo
mejor más justo más equitativo
en lo profesional les cuento que la vida
me dio una pequeña revancha y me
permitió acercarme de nuevo a este
primer sueño de atender mujeres
embarazadas y toda su circunstancia ya
que desde hace algunos años trabajo
entre otros lugares en una maternidad
pública en donde se trata muy bien a las
mujeres no solo en lo médico sino
también en lo humano y en lo social
mi amiga lucía la ingeniera volvió
argentina tiene también una familia y
dos hijos preciados los hijos de maría
crecieron sin maría ahora son adultos y
cada uno lleva adelante su vida
en nombre de las marías de las luz y as
de los hijos de maría de las mujeres que
murieron a causa de abortos inseguros y
de las que se siguen muriendo es
necesario que este proyecto se
cristalice en ley argentina necesita y
se merece
una ley que facilite el acceso al aborto
muchas gracias
gracias